ونستمر معكم مشاهدينا على شاشه العربيه في
هذه التغطيه الحيه والمباشره لتداعيات
الزلزال الذي وقع جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا
لليوم الرابع على التوالي نستمر في هذه
التغطيه وتستمر فرق الانقاذ في جهودها على
جانبي الحدود بحثا عن مزيد من الناجين او
انتشالي جثث الضحايا في الارقام وصل عدد
القتلى في تركيا الى
16,170 قتيلا حتى الان واكثر من 64 الف
مصاب بينما في سوريا اعلن المرصد ان عدد
القتلى تجاوز
373 قتيله
الحمد لله على سلامته والله عايشين وطيبين
وما في احسن منه والله عايشين
الحمد لله الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
الحمد
لله
[موسيقى]
وهتتواصل الجهود الانسانيه
لمؤازره المنكوبين اعلنت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه عن انطلاق الجسر الجوي لاغاثه
متضرري الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا وسنعرض
على حضراتكم هذه الصور التي تاتينا من ارض
مطار الملك خالد الدوليه بالرياض حيث
تستعد اليات ومعدات من فرق الدفاع المدني
السعودي لشحنها عبر طائره خاصه استعدادا
لانطلاقها الليله الى مطار اضنه التركي
ضمن حمله المساعدات التي امر بها العاهل
السعودي الملك سلمان وولي عهده الامير
محمد بن سلمان
العمل الانساني السعودي هو عمل انساني بحث
غير مرتبط باي اي جده سياسيه دينيه عرقيه
ولذلك الفرق التي ذهبت توجيه التي لديها
العمل لرفع او لمساعده المحتاجين من هذا
الزلزال دون النظر للموقع او المكان او اي
دوافع اخرى بالنسبه لما يصدر من جهات او
دول او منظمات
العمل كما كنا نعمل في السابق مع عدد كبير
من المنظمات الامميه والدوليه وكذلك
المنظمات الغير ربحيه في سوريا الموثوقه
نعمل معهم
وبدانا بالفعل منذ ان صدر التوجيه الكريم
بالتواصل معهم ولنا موثوقيه عاليه في هذه
المنظمات التي نعمل معها ولدينا اليات
رقابه
لضمان
الانسان السعودي يصل للمحتاجين بصرف النظر
عن مواقع
وننتقل الان الى كلمه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان قررت من هذا الزلزال
مؤسسه الاسكان التركيه
بتنسيق مع وزاره الاسكان
والبيئه
سيساهمان في اعاده اعمار هذه المدن في
اقصر وقت وقت ممكن
بالطبع الاولويه لانقاذ الارواح وازاله
الانقاذ وبعد ذلك
سنعيد اعمار هذه المدن والشركات التي
ستساهم وتساعد في اعاده الاعمار ستقوم
برفع الانقاذ هنا
وافراغها وبعد ذلك سيتم اعاده الاعمار
فيها
في زلزال فان وفي زلزال بينجل وفي زلزال
ازمر وايضا
في الاونه الاخيره زلازل وملاطيا كما
تذكرون وايضا في فيضانات مدينه كاستمونو
حرائق الغابات في انطاليا ومولا
تتذكرون كيف سارعنا الى اعاده اعمار كل
هذه المدن بعد كل هذه الازل والفيضانات
والحرائق الدوله التركيه في هذه المره
ايضا ستقف الى جانب ابنائها ومواطنيها
وتعيد اعمار العشر مدن المنكوبه
سيعود
المتضررين من هذه الزلازل الى منازلهم
امنين مؤمنين وبشكل سليم بعد اعاده
الاعمار شكرا جزيلا
لاحقا
هون
[موسيقى]
يلا براءه
يلا عمار يلا يلا
يلا
تعال تعال غطيها تعال
جهود الانقاذ تستمر وخط المساعدات ايضا
يسعى لمحاوله تخفيف المعاناه الامين العام
للعمومي المتحده انطونيو كان قد اعلن في
مؤتمر صحفي منذ قليل انه دخلت بالفعل اول
شحنه من المساعدات الامميه الى الشمال
السوري والذي كان يعاني بشده من غياب
المساعدات الامين العام للامم المتحده اكد
انه تم بالفعل دخول شحنه جديده من
المساعدات تضم ست شاحنات تضم وسائل
للتدفئه وبعض الاغذيه وانها نجحت بالفعل
في عبور معبر باب الهوى بعد 60 ساعه تحت
الركام تم انقاذه طفل يبلغ من العمر 20
يوما في مدينه هاتاي التركيه وبعد انقاضه
لوحظ ان اصابع الطفل الصغير كانت من
متشابكه في شعر امه
[موسيقى]
الساعه 4:12
لا اله الا الله
ولمتابعه حيه ومباشره مع شبكه مراسل
العربيه على الارض ننتقل الى هاتاي موفد
العربيه عمار الهندي مرحبا بك عمار كان
اردوغان يتحدث منذ قليل عن ارتفاع اعداد
القتلى وانها تجاوزت 16 الف قتيل حتى
اللحظه كيف تبدو جهود العقاد بعد ان دخل
الليل في ساعاته الاولى
انا رشا انتقلت الى مكان اخر الرقم الذي
يتحدث فيه زيدان وتتحدث فيه الارقام
الرسميه منطقي جدا مقارنه بهذا الدمار
الهائل الذي يعني يحدث
ومستمر في هاتاي وفي مختلف المدن التركيه
انس ادع الكاميرا تشرح لك يعني وتشاهدي
اثر الدمار الكبير في احدى احياء هاتاي
نحن انتقلنا الى موقع اخر هذه ساطلب من
الزميل ان ينتف بالكاميرا من اليسار الى
اقصى اليمين وتشاهدي كل هذا المشهد هذه
البنايات المدمره رشا لا تزال عشرات
العائلات تحت انقاضها يعني انا كنت تحدثت
للتو وعلمت بان عائلات سوريه وعائلات
يمنيه واشخاص كثر لا يزال تحت انقاض طبعا
هناك انقطاع للكهرباء عمار لذلك يبدو
الظلام واضحا في الصور
صحيح الكهرباء لم تعود حتى هذه اللحظه الى
هاتاي شبكه الاتصالات يعني شبه معطله
الانترنت معطل بشكل كامل وهذا طبعا يعيق
عمل الفرق الانقاذ يستخدمون مولدات في كل
ما يفعلون هذه الحرائق النيران التي
تشاهدينها يعني يشعلها اشخاص اقارب هؤلاء
الناس المتواجدين العالقين لا يزالوا حتى
هذه اللحظه تحت الانقاض والباحثين عن مصر
والكاميرا نجح في الاقتراب بالصوره قليلا
لبعض المعدات التي تقوم بعمليه الانقاذ في
هذه المنطقه
نعم انا ساتحرك اساسا سانزل من اعلى هذا
الجسر الذي نقف عليه الى اسفل الموقع الذي
فيه هذا الانهيار وفيه هذا الدمار ونحن
طبعا نسير يمكن ان تشاهدي هذا الظلام
الدامس في في هاتاي والدمار الكبير جدا
طبعا كما تعلمين الهزات الارتداديه لا
تزال تجري وتحدث في هاتاي منذ صباح هذا
اليوم وعددها كبير جدا ونحن تحديدا نقف
على الجسر نشعر بها بشكل واضح تماما لان
الجسر يهتز كلما جاءت هذه الهزات
الارتداديه طبعا هنالك عده بنايات يجري
الحديث فيها عن وجود ناجين من جنسيات
مختلفه وهم يبحثون عنهم هنالك عائله فيها
هنالك بنايه فيها ثلاث شبان سوريين يبحثون
عنهم ولكن هنالك ايضا في المقابل رشا عدد
كبير من العائلات التي لا تتواجد انا
ساتحدث
انا ساتحدث الى شخص هنا شاب من عائله
يمنيه لديه رشا عائله كامله باكملها لا
تزال تحت الانقاض سانتقل انا وهو الى
الداخل نتحدث سويه
تحياتي صديقي لو تقترب الكاميرا اكثر تحكي
لنا بس انتم اولا نتعرف عليك عبد الاله
طاهر من اليمن اهلا وسهلا فيك كم عائله
والله لنا اربعه اشخاص من هم زوجه ابن
خالي
واختها
وولدها وبنتها بنتها عمرها سنه عمرها سنه
نعم في اي بناء في
البناء اللي هنا
وقربوا يوصلون
للضحايا قربوا الانجاز الله يعطيهم
العافيه امين يا رب ايش طمنوكم في اصوات
من هناك تصدر في اشي في اي بشائر بانهم
احياء والله لا نعلم لا احنا ولا اهم ولكن
عمليه الانقاذ 24 ساعه
شغالين الله يعطيهم العافيه الحمد لله على
كل حال سمعت انه في حدا من العائله جسده
واضح او مبين صح اطراف من جسمه نعم امين
كم عمره
17 سنه يعني هو توفى
الله يرحمه تاكدت الله يرحمه وعزائنا لكم
الحمد لله الحمد في عائلات كثيره تحت هذا
المبنى نعم نعم في عائلات كثيره والحمد
لله وزي ما تشوفون ما بيدنا شيء وعمليه
الانجاز 24 ساعه الله يعطيهم العافيه ما
قصروا كل شيء موفرينه كل الخدمات موفره
وهذا امر الله طبعا والنعم بالله طبعا
انتم متواجدين من اول لحظه يعني
ثانيه الاب اب الاسره لم يكن موجود صح لا
كان في اضنه كان في مدينه اضنه لحظه
وقوع الزلزال طبعا الزلزال عندنا وهنا بس
عندنا الاضرار اخف
فاجينا لهنا الحمد لله هذا يعني نعزيكم
بمن تاكدت وفاته ونتامل انه البقيه يكونوا
على قيد الحياه ان شاء الله يعني طب انتم
اين تباتون تباتون هنا يعني متواصلين في
البقاء هون نعم نعم في سياراتكم سياراتنا
ومنتظرين الى ان الله يفرج علينا ان شاء
الله يفرجها قريبا ان شاء الله وانا كنت
استمعت لاشخاص سوريين ايضا لديهم عائلات
هنا لا تزال تحت الانقاد نتمنى ان شاء
الله النجال للجميع وينفرج الى الجميع
رجاء يعني هذا هذه كانت شهاده احد الاشخاص
الذي لديهم حقيقه عائله لا عائله لا تزال
تحت انقاض هذا المبنى محتجزه تحت انقاذ
هذا المبنى ساحاول اقترب اكثر ان كانت
الكاميرا
توصلنا الى المكان بشكل هذه
سيارات العائلات التي تنتظر ضحاياها ام
سيارات مسؤوليه
وكل من يتواجد هنا ويشعل النيران هم
للعائلات التي جاءت تنتظر تحديد مصير
ذويهم ومن ومن بقيوا تحت الانقاب طبعا
العمليات شكرا عمار سنبقى معك ومع التغطيه
ولكن ننتقل الى كلمه وزير الصحه في
الحكومه السوريه
بناء على طلب من الاصدقاء وطلب من المحبين
للشعب السوري ولم يعني نطلبها لانه يعني
بادرنا نحن بالطلب هم سالونا ماذا تحتاجون
وارسلنا لهم هذه القوائم وجدنا منهم كل
استجابه وكل محبه
فنحن لدينا مخزون اكيد من الادويه ولدينا
مخزون للطوارئ وموجودين على الارض بكل
الكوادر والفعاليه
ما حدث اكيد يسبب استنزاف للقطاع الصحي
المطلوب منا اكبر تقديم الخدمه اليوم في
المعاوي التي تؤوي المواطنين اللي هربوا
من منازلهم المتصدع وهم يعني ممكن يكون في
عنا مشكله اكبر قد يواجه القطاع الصحي انه
هذه المباني قد تكون قايله للسقوط او
الانهيار او تقرر اللجان الهندسيه والفنيه
عدم صلاحيتها للسكن فاكيد هدول الاخوه
المواطنين واجبنا تقديم الرعايه الصحيه
الكامله لهم مع باقي متطلبات الحياه
الضروريه
شكرا
البريه السوريه
سؤال الاول معالي الوزير بعد اربعه ايام
تقريبا على هذه الكارثه الانسانيه فعلا ما
هي اكثر الامور الذي يحتاجها القطاع الصحي
والطب اليوم في سوريا الادويه ام الاجهزه
ام الطواقم الطبيه ام سيارات الاسعاف سؤال
ثاني لو سمحت مساله تحرير القيود على
القطاع الصحي في سوريا هل هناك مؤشرات
فعليا على هذا الامر تحدثت يعني بشكل كبير
عن مساله العقوبات وتاثيرها لكن خلال ايام
الماضي كان في كتير تصريحات من من الدول
الغربيه عن امكانيه وصول المساعدات الطبيه
او الرعايه الصحيه الى سوريا ردكم على هذه
النقطه بالذات هل في مؤشرات حقيقيه على
الموضوع شكرا
استاذ نحن الموضوع ليس سجال الموضوع وقائع
ومؤشرات وارقام
واضحه ودقيقه لدينا في وزاره الصحه وفي كل
الوزارات السوريه
الجميع بيعرف انه قبل الحرب
الظالمه على سوريا وما فرض على سوريا كان
القطاع الصحي في سوريا مضرب مثل يعني في
المنطقه وهذا معروف للجميع ويشيد به الكل
حتى الاعداء يشدون به نحن اليوم بعد سنوات
طويله من الحرب تم استهلاك الكثير من هذه
الاجهزه صار في ضعف اكيد بتوريد ما هو
جديد
تم فرض عقوبات على الموردين وهذا واقع
وموجودين يعني ممكن سؤال والوصول لهم
بسهوله ولدينا البيانات نحن لا نتكلم يعني
انه
لنجد مبررات
حاجه القطاع الصحي بالدرجه الاولى بكل
تاكيد هو التجهيزات الكبيره هذا ما ذكرته
اليوم طلبه من منظمه الصحه العالميه اذكره
كطبيب لما بتنتشر المصاب من تحت الانقاض
في كارثه مثل في حلت بنا انت بتحتاج انه
تصوره
باجهزه باهظه الثمن لتوصل لتشخيص دقيق
لتقدر تساوي له اجراء جراحي صحيح مانو
الموضوع هو يعني عم نطلب وجود هذه
التجهيزات الكبيره والمكلفه ما عم نطلب
وجودها ترف والجميع يعلم ذلك والاطباء
يعني الكل من زار سوريا وزار ما شافنا
يعرف هذا الكلام موضوع المشافي اكيد نحن
بنحتاج لمشاكل لانه كثير من البنيه
التحتيه في القطاع الصحي دمرت كلكم
شاهدتوا لدينا كان يعني مشفى اورام لداغي
مشافي اورام كبيره في العالم بحلب كيف تم
تفجيره بالكامل اكيد نحن هذا بيحتاج
لسنوات للاموال طائله نحن عم نحكي على
الحاجه الطارئه الحاجه الطارئه هي
التجهيزات الطبيه الاساسيه اضافه
للتجهيزات الطبيه الطارئه سالت زميلتنا
سؤال يتعلق نحن اليوم بعد اربع ايام على
يعني لحظه الكارثه بعتقد تجاوزنا جزء عام
منا
اي ابلغنا ان طائر صينيه ابلغتنا لجنه ان
طائره صينيه تهبط الان في المطار والصين
حاضره دوما مع الشعب السوري كما ذكرت
واؤكد على هذه النقطه
فالحاجه بالمبدا للتجهيزات الكبيره التي
تعمل في المشافي
تليها الادويه وخاصه الادويه المشافي
يعطيك العافيه ساعات وزير اذاعه شام اف ام
بدايه بسالك عن دور المشافي الخاصه
بالمحافظات المنكوبه هل عم يكون في تساهل
باستقبال المنكوبين بمختلف المحافظات
السؤال الثاني من مبدا من سمع ليس كمن راى
خلال يوم امس تواجدنا بمحافظه دمشق خلال
عمليات الانقاذ بمنطقه حرسته انصح التعبير
الاليات التي تعمل او العمال على الاليات
غير مدربين على الانقاذ ان صح التعبير فهل
هناك كادر بطبيعه الحال يعمل على الاليات
عنده يمتلك الخبره الكافيه لعمليات
الانقاذ
تابعنا كلمه وزير الصحه في حكومه الاسد
حسن الغباش الذي تحدث عن التحديات التي
تواجه القطاع الصحي
الرسمي السوري عقب هذه الكارثه مناشدا
المنظمات والدول لتقديم الدعم وقال انه تم
ارسال قوائم باحتياجات هذا القطاع للعديد
من الدول التي وصفها بالصديقه وانه تمت
الاستجابه يقول ايضا انه وهو على الهواء
دخلت بالفعل شاحنه صينيه تحمل مساعدات
ودعم للقطاع الصحي في سوريا وقال ان هذه
كارثه كبيره للغايه تحتاج الى دعم دولي
كبير اعود مره اخرى الى الزميل عمار
الهندي في هاتايا وكنا نتابع معه جهود
الانقاذ المستمره حتى اللحظه ربما يكون من
المبكر طرح هذا السؤال عمار ولكن هل
استمعتم من رجال الانقاب عن اي تحديد زمني
لانتهاء هذه
الجهود ام انه من المبكر للغايه التفكير
في هذا الامر
انا سالت احد رجال الانقاذ وهو عربي يعمل
في بنايه ثانيه وقال لي اجرني رفع يديه
يعني لانه بالفعل انا لا اعتقد انهم
سيتوقفوا عن العمل لانه طالما ان هنالك
امل بوجود ناجين طبعا نحن انا كنت انا
يعني انهيت كان اخر كلامي قبل ان ننتقل
للمؤتمر الصحفي عامل الوقت رشا نحن في
تحدي كبير اليوم سينتهي اليوم الرابع
سندخل في اليوم الخامس ويعني موضوع ان
يبقى شخص على قيد الحياه خمسه ايام تحت
الانقاض بدون غذاء مع برد قارس بدون ماء
هذا تحدي كبير جدا ويحتاج الى معجزات ولكن
بما انهم اليوم اخرجوا اناس على قيد
الحياه فالامل لا زال موجود المشكله
الحقيقيه ان هنالك رشا بنايات كثيره
ومناطق كثيره لم تبدا فيها حتى عمليات
البحث تحت الانقاض وازاله الانقاض وذلك
بسبب الضغط لا ادري ان كنت يعني شاهدت
الصور التي كانت معنا لسيده تركيه كانت
تصرخ وتبكي وتشتكي بان لديها اثنين من
عائلتها تحت هذا البناء وتقول اين رجال
الانقاذ تخيل المشهد انا ساطلب من الزميل
ان يلتفت بالكاميرا كل هذه الاعمال تتم
بدون اضاءه يعني الاضاءه خافته جدا بسيطه
جدا قليله جدا
الاضاءه مهمه في هذه الاحيان هناك اشعال
للنيران لمحاوله الاضاءه على ما يبدو
او التدفئه والتدفئه لانه الدرجات الحراره
كانت في اليوم خلال النهار مشمسه ولكن
الان بدات برد شديد جدا
وصلت الى هذه المنطقه عمار ام ان فقط على
الارض رجال وفرق الانقاذ
على الارض فقط رجال الانقاذ وفرق الانقاذ
ومتطوعين ليسوا فقط اتراك هنالك وفود
كثيره هنالك وفود عربيه وهنالك وفط صيني
انا رايته يعمل وهنالك وفود اوروبيه تعمل
الجميع هنا يعمل الكل صراحه هنالك ارباك
كبير رشا يعني صراحه يعني هنالك كميه
هائله من المباني هنالك ركام كثير هنا
وهناك اينما نظرتي وبالتالي العدد قليل
عدد من يعملون قليل مهما كان هنالك
تعزيزات ومتطوعين يبقى
في مقابل هذا الدمار رشا العدد قليل
وبالتالي يعني الامور الامور لا نستطيع ان
طبعا من المبكر ان نقول انها ربما يعني
هنالك الامل باتا بصيص الامل باتا بسيط او
قليل جدا في العثور على ناجين ولكن الوقت
يداهم الجميع يعني اليوم كما قلت لك
سينتهي اليوم الرابع فجرا وسندخل في اليوم
الخامس ونتمنى طبعا ان يكون هنالك اشخاص
ناجين تحت الانقاض وانا اشكرك عمار على
هذه الصور وعلى هذه التغطيه المستمره على
شاشه العربيه زميلي عمار الهندي منها طايق
موفد العربيه شكرا لك
عزيزتي تحياتي لك
ولباساهدين دعما بالفعل دخلت قافله اليوم
من بعد ساعات لكن فيها محتواها بعض يعني
بعض
النظافه
بطانيه
طبعا
بان هذه القاره التي دخلت
الزلزال وعلى الاعتبار
اذا هناك صعوبه في وسائل الاتصال ولكن اذا
كان يمكن
ان من جديد ربما يظهر الصوت بصوره اوضح
نعم
محتواها بعد شلل
طبعا الصوت فيه مشكله احمد لا نستطيع ان
نسمعك بشكل جيد الصحفي احمد ابو لؤي من
ريف حلب شكرا لك ولكنه اكد بالفعل دخول
المساعدات التي تحدث عنها انطونيو
غوتيريوس الامين العام للامم المتحده الى
الشمال السوري منذ قليل والتي تضم ست
شاحنات تضم وسائل للتدفئه والتغذيه وهذا
يعد مؤشر جيد دخلت هذه الشاحنات من معبر
باب الهوى لمحاوله التصدي للوضع الكارثي
في الشمال السوري
نحن لا زلنا في وسط مدينه هاتاي لليوم
الرابع على الثواني عمليات البحث عن
الناجين تحت الانقاض مستمره هذا هو المشهد
الحاصل والدمار الهائل في مدينه هاتاي
الالاف يعملون هنا على
مدارس هل لهم يستمعون الى صوت اي اشخاص
تحت الان
قاب ايه رده
فعل الصباح
هزات ارتداديه ضربت ووسط مدينه هاتاي
الجميع هنا في سباق مع الزمن للعثور على
الناجين والمفقودين تحت الانقاذ الاسر هنا
هذا مشهدهم وهم ينتظرون
على ايه معلومه تدل على مصير ذويه
م تحت مليات ستبقى مستمره حتى يعني ازاله
اخر
انقاض ودمار من هذه البنايات الموجوده في
هاتاي لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار الهندي
مشهد اقرب لافلام الخيال التي تتحدث عن
الفناء لا شيء يوحي بان هذه الارض كانت
تنبض بالحياه يوما ما
يا شباب افواج من البشر حائره بين الترقب
والحزن والرثاء واصوات بكاء يكسرها ضجيج
الالات التي تحفر هنا وهناك على تحمل بين
جرافات خبر نجاه احدهم او ربما خبر رحيل
اخر اخر
ارواح بالالاف ازهقت وعبارات الترحب باتا
تتردد في كل مكان جثث العالقين لم تعد تجد
سوى الالحفه لاحتضانها قبل ان تعود الى
التراب مره اخرى وهذه المره ليس تحت
الركام بل داخل قبور ستظل شهيده على احدى
اكثر الكوارث الطبيعيه بشاعه
[موسيقى]
بدك تنامي
ما نمتي يا عمري
سلامتك يا روحي
[موسيقى]
يلا هلا بتنامي يا عمري
تكرم عينك